[Music]
what if the dimension of time was no
different from the three dimensions of
space we live in what if you could
travel to the past and to the future the
same way you can move right or left up
or down would you be able to change the
past and if you did would it create a
time paradox what kind of time machine
would you need to build anyway this is
what if and here's what would happen if
you could travel two times how many
times have you wished you could jump in
a time machine and skip that boring
meeting or choose a bitter comeback in
that argument last week time travel
sounds like some wild fantasy that only
happens in sci-fi movies but we're
actually traveling in time every day
Albert Einstein found that time is not a
constant but it's continually moving
forward and we're moving forward with it
according to Einstein time is the fourth
dimension together with
three-dimensional space it's fused into
a single four-dimensional continuum
space-time if you think of traveling in
space moving upwards is a bit of a
challenge unless we get on a plane or at
least take the stairs so maybe we just
haven't come up with a proper machine to
travel in time yet theoretically
building a time machine is possible but
it wouldn't look like this or like this
rather more like this because the secret
to time travel isn't in some exotic form
of matter what you'd need is a spaceship
that could travel almost as fast as
light
Einstein's theory of relativity taught
us that the faster we move through space
the slower we move in time let's assume
you were in a spaceship traveling at
99.9 percent the speed of light to a
potentially habitable exoplanet some 40
light years away you find some primitive
life-forms and speed back to earth to
share your discovery but when you
finally make it back to earth you
discover that all your colleagues are
now very very old from your perspective
you'd only been gone for about two years
for people on earth you'd been gone for
80 this phenomenon is known as time
dilation it's not likely to happen to
you though because traveling at the
speed of light isn't quite possible with
the technology we have now the fastest
piloted vehicle we've ever created
Apollo 10 reached a speed of 11,000
meters per second the speed needed for
time travel is somewhere near 299
million meters per second on top of that
accelerating at that speed would cause
an enormous centrifugal force a force
that would rip you apart before you came
anywhere close to light speed but hey we
still have wormholes Einstein predicted
that these theoretical tunnels linked
two separate places and two different
times a shortcut to another universe and
another time
the problem with wormholes is they're
extremely tiny just a billion trillion
trillionth of a centimeter across no
human would be able to fit through
I can barely fit in my jeans from last
year if only we could capture a wormhole
we might be able to enlarge it imagine a
giant tunnel above the earth leading to
another planet and theoretically if we
put both ends of a wormhole in the same
place but in different times we could
step into a wormhole and come out in the
distant past but wormholes have their
issues they're very short-lived and
traveling into the past would create
paradoxes like the one in which you go
back in time and convinced your
grandmother never to get married then
your grandmother doesn't give birth to
your dad
he doesn't have you but if you didn't
exist who went back in time to talk your
grandmother out of marrying your
grandfather time is linear it only goes
forward for that reason we can only
travel into the future not to the past
in fact astronauts that spent about a
year on the International Space Station
are now living in the future compared to
us even though it's just 13 milliseconds
in the future they're proof that
traveling a time is possible and maybe
wormholes could open up a whole
different world where the laws of
physics work in different ways and
traveling to the past is possible would
you dare step into a time machine not
knowing where it would take you and if
you had the choice where would you go
and when
[Music]
you